jetzt geht es ganz konkret um die Ampel
man feiert naja einjähriges es ist ihr
Thema wir ziehen einmal Bilanz wie steht
die Regierung heute da ja es gibt ja ein
frei nach einem alten deutschen
Volkslied kann man sagen einmal werden
wir noch wach heißer dann ist Jahrestag
morgen also wird es genau ein Jahr sein
seit die deutsche ampelregierung uns als
Bundesregierung beglückt es ist ein
Jubiläum das also kein Anlass zum Feiern
bietet was hat man uns denn alles
versprochen einen neuen Stil hat man
versprochen man wolle nun auf Augenhöhe
regieren man wolle eine lernende Politik
machen stattdessen sehe ich den alten
Stil man streitet miteinander die
Steigerung von Feind Parteifreund ist
Kabinettskollege man steckt durch
negative Nachrichten über den
Kabinettskollegen an jede Presse und
wenn nicht der Meinung ist der Regierung
der wird bestimmt man hat sogar eine
eine eigene deutschen
beschimpfungsbeauftragte eingestellt
nämlich Frau Vater mann mann hat
versprochen eine neue Art der
Fortschritte zu stattdessen sehe ich
Rückschritt die Leute sind nicht wie es
uns verhießen worden war fröhlicher
geworden zuversichtlicher sie sind
geknechtet fühlen sich geknechtet
gedrückt gewiss wir haben auch eine
schwierige Lage eine schwierige
Situation das will ich nicht in Abrede
stellen aber alles in allem verströmt
diese Regierung nicht was sie
versprochen hatte keine
zukunftsversicherheit keine neuen Stil
und vor allen Dingen keine neue
Kompetenz sagen wir nur die Namen die
damit verbunden sind Frau Fräser Herr
Lauterbach und vielleicht auch sogar
noch Frau Lambrecht alle kamen wie die
Jungfrau zum Kinder zu Ministeramt alle
machen dort eine sehr sehr schlechte
Figur also wir haben wenig kompetent wir
haben keinen neues Stil wir haben keinen
Fortschritt wir haben keine neue Kultur
des Respekt ich muss sagen dieser
Jahreszeit ist wirklich kein Grund zum
Feiern zum Feiern vielleicht eher zum
Feiern
also die Schulnote die wir noch
verteilen wollen ich höre raus ist es
noch eine fünf mangelhaft
befriedigend noch befriedigend Herr
Ernst finden Sie irgendwelche positiven
Punkte in der Regierung wenn sie jetzt
mal vielleicht ganz unerwartet in die
Presse springen und sagen moment mal
die Regierung verteidigen
meine Kritik und diese Regierung
allgemein gehalten einfach an Personen
festgemacht und an Kompetenz die
vielleicht nicht vorhanden ist ich
glaube der Hauptkritik an der Regierung
der besteht darin dass man mit Methoden
auf eine Krise reagiert die die eigenen
Leute ruiniert
zum Beispiel den Lauterbach in die
Gesundheitsreform ist dringend notwendig
ja und das was er sagt ist auch richtig
dass man wir müssen das
Gesundheitswissen wegbringen von diesem
Profit denken ja das ist natürlich
richtig angekündigt
gemacht
brauchen Profit nicht um
Gesundheitssystem Gesundheit
orientiert es kommt raus ein
fallsystemen System das z.B im
Kinderbereich dazu führt dass nichts
mehr funktioniert weil Kinder einfach in
dieses fallsystem nicht reinpassen und
wenn man im Krankenhaus ist und ich war
vor kurz drin dann merkt man auch dass
man den Eindruck hat das ist ein System
das so funktioniert dass er möglichst
schnell auch wieder rauskommt aus dem
will sondern weil dann das Soll erfüllt
ist man ist drin die Klinik kriegt ihr
vollpauschalen System bezahlt sie kriegt
dann das Geld bezahlt das vorgesehen ist
aber dann ist besser
er will vieles er wollte auch eine
vernünftige Politik machen in Corona ist
grandios gescheit hat gewarnt nur vor
Frühling Sommer Herbst und winterpalet
in jedem Bälle gegen jeden Tag mit der
Alarmglocke durch die Landschaft
niemanden in den eigentlich nicht mehr
ernst und weil ich kann überhaupt kein
einziges Problem vorstellen dass bei
Herrn Lauterbach in guten Händen lege
kein einziges und dieses schwierige
Problem da haben sie recht da haben die
Vorgängerregierung viel versäumt aber
das liegt ganz gewiss nicht in der
Kompetenz von der Lauterbach da nur eine
bestverbesserung zu erstellen
anfangs ein bisschen wie beim
Tischtennis geguckt und dann haben sie
aber als er lauterbachkarte haben sie
gelacht
zum Thema mit die Krankenhäuser schnell
rauskommen tut mir Moment weil die
überfüllt sind ja vor allem jetzt weil
viele Kinderstationen überfüllt sind
aber als die noch nicht überfüllt waren
ist immer so schnell draußen kommen da
ist es schon vor allem übers Wochenende
im Krankenhaus für eine bestimmte
Krankheit gibt es eine pauschale
sozusagen und wie lange wenn wenn sie
schneller wieder draußen sind aus dem
Krankenhaus liegt ist Krankenhaus
trotzdem das Geld konnten einen neuen
Patienten wieder aufnehmen insofern hat
es im Krankenhaus nicht das Interesse
würde ich vielleicht früher nicht
ableiten dass die Ampel bessere Arbeit
macht weil er Lauterbach eine von seinen
33.000 Pressekonferenzen diesem Thema
widmet bitte
die Frage war an mich gerichtet was
finde gut
ich finde die gut dass wenn jetzt
tatsächlich ist zu einer Veränderung
dieses Profit durchschlagen
Gesundheitssystem kommt wenn es wieder
nach der Frage geht dass der Patient die
Mittelpunkt steht wenn der Mensch die
Grill das nicht an den Gesundheit nicht
als wahre behandelt
dann ist es positiv und die Frage war
was ist positiv das finde ich positiv
dass man das angeht okay Alter Regierung
hat übrigens nicht gemacht
politiker sprechen oder fühlen Sie sich
da abgeholt ja die sind natürlich
rhetorische sehr gut gut
es wird entlassen die wo eigentlich noch
nicht wirklich fit sind es vor allem
Kinder es war ja schlecht
der jetzigen Regierung
noch ihre eigene Geschichte gegen 5
also mir fällt jetzt nicht viel Gutes
ein im Moment auch eine Umfrage beim
Spiel jeder
Außenminister wird schlecht bewertet
jeder einzeln das war noch nie so das
ist keine Delle der Zustimmung ist ein
Krater mittlerweile
in der Politik das soll man sie anschaut
das ist ja einfach mit maschinenz ja im
Ausland für das was bei uns drin hockt
naja alle für alle nicht für alle super
Grundqualifikation her für die Menschen
die hier regieren bei unternehmen können
so eine Equipment das ist ein Problem
und das traurige ist immer das wollen
sie jetzt gern hören aber
eigentlich verdienen Politiker in dem
Fall dann zu wenig weil dann eben keine
Fachkräfte rein kriegen ohne das was man
so drin haben haben am meisten von allen
EU-Staatschefs war heute zu lesen schon
mal nicht schlecht 30.000 € im Monat
dafür hört man ja sehr viel von ihm in
der Zeit zumindest hat er viele viele
Milliarden zur Verfügung gestellt für
die Bundeswehr das war also die gute
Nachricht oder
kann ich nicht unbedingt immer als gute
Nachricht hinnehmen gerade weil da auch
ein gewisse die Realität halt ein
bisschen schmerzhafter ist was was
hinter solchen Investitionen steht und
gerade was jetzt auch an Lieferungen ins
Ausland stattfindet muss man sie halt
immer mal vor Augen führen was das auch
für Auswirkung hat und was es für
Auswirkungen hat habe ich sehen müssen
und erfahren und das ist halt bei weitem
lebensverändernder als man das hier
vielleicht wahrnimmt und solche Zahlen
machen vielleicht erstmal die Truppe
auch wieder ein bisschen motivierter
weil man natürlich an allen Ecken und
Enden merkt wo es habe das Ausrüstung
einfach veraltet ist und Sachen einfach
nicht auf dem neuesten Stand sind ich
meine da bin ich in der komfortablen
Lage gewesen mit meiner Einheit aber der
gro der gemerkt wo waren sie da genau wo
sie gemerkt haben
sind wir hier überhaupt wo war der Punkt
wo sie das gesehen hat gerade die
Grundausrüstung die Basis Ausstattung da
wird er jetzt dann dran gearbeitet
gerade dass die Leute auch mal
vernünftige Winterklamotten bekommen
also das ist ja
eine absolute Katastrophe im 21
Jahrhundert es gibt es gab schon welche
aber die die es gab die zieht sich halt
mit Wasser voll ohne Ende
die gotex Textilien die es vorher gab
die waren so an Qualität einfach
minderwertig dass man das eigentlich für
ein längeren Aufenthalt draußen nicht
gebrauchen konnte und jetzt ändert man
ja da so ein bisschen was also das was
vorher vielleicht nur für spezialisiert
und Spezialkräfte verwendet werden
durfte wird jetzt ein bisschen auch für
die breitere Masse genommen hätten sie
die Bundeswehr für verteidigungsfähig
aktuell aufgrund dieser
gesundheitsthematik die wir ja später
besprechen werden ist das sehr
fragwürdig und das ist eigentlich die
Katastrophe die aktuell
ja umgeht weil gerade wenn wir jetzt
sehen was für Konflikt wir jetzt haben
und dass die Landes und
bundesverteidigung ja eigentlich mehr
denn je wichtig ist bin ich der festen
Überzeugung dass wir da starke Probleme
haben das übrigens ein Punkt wo ich die
Ampel fast den Schutz nehmen muss also
das kaputt waren der Bundeswehr be unter
Union nämlich unter dem Israel seit 2005
glaube ich hat die Union ohne
Unterbrechung den Verteidigungsminister
oder Ministerin gestellt und damals kam
das Wort auf das werde ich nicht
vergessen vom operativen Minimum also
gerade so viel haben gemerkte das ist
irgendwie reicht kein Vorrat haben keine
Lagerhaltung operatives Minimum aber
kann man in einem Jahr gar nichts
verändern immer wird entschuldigt mit
der Vergangenheit das macht die
Regierung ja auch gesagt aber es wurden
viele Fehler in der Vergangenheit und
jetzt baden wir es ausmachen
Verteidigungsministerium glaube ich das
ist wirklich wenn Sie auch wissen ein
sehr sehr großer Apparate 10
Lobbyverbände dran Rüstungsindustrie
Abgeordnete andere Interessen
verschiedenste Art das ist wirklich ein
ganz großer dicker kann Tanker und umso
wichtiger wer ist da jemand zu haben der
wirklich dafür brennt der auch eine
Expertise hat und der nicht nur wie vor
Lambrecht nur auf diesem Posten
zwischengeparkt wurde damit sie später
Innenminister werden kann das war
nämlich die Verabredung sie sitzen lange
im Bundestag war dieses Thema denn nicht
präsent war das den Politiker nicht
bewus ist unsere Bundeswehr stellen wir
fest sagt hier ein Soldat der sich
auskennt ist nicht verteidigungsfähig
wenn der Soldat klagt dass er Pflicht
die Klamotten oder wahrscheinlich die
Erfahrung gemacht das ist so ist es will
überhaupt nicht leugnen meine Frage ist
eine andere wenn die die NATO insgesamt
fast eine Milliarde ausgibt im Jahr für
Rüstung insgesamt die NATO Staaten die
Russen und die Chinesen zusammen ca 320
Milliarden dann frag ich mich warum wir
eigentlich noch mehr ausgeben müssen
sondern dann wenn schon dann muss man
vielleicht über die Frage der Effizienz
reden für was geht man das Geld aus aber
ich sehe nicht die Notwendigkeit ein
angesichts der Verhältnisse der
Zahlenverhältnisse dass die NATO
sozusagen eine dreifache zumindest
finanzielle Überlegenheit hat gegenüber
den potenziellen feinstaaten
untergegangen
dann dann schließe ich mir die
Notwendigkeit eines 2% Ziels überhaupt
nicht und die erschließt sich für mich
auch nicht die Möglichkeit von 100
Milliarden ich fahr zur Zeit viel mit
bauen das wird man investieren dass die
wieder funktioniert dass sie pünktlich
ist dass der diesen Wagen funktioniert
wir sollten das Geld in die Bildung
stecken weil wir haben auch Defizit
in die Bundeswehr würde ich in die
Bundeswehr würde ich zu als Steigerung
des rüstungssetals nicht verwenden weil
ich eben dargestellt habe dass wir eine
dreifache Überlegenheit der NATO starten
haben wenn wir alleine so viel ausgeben
wie die Russen ja wir sind Teil der NATO
dann dann muss ich sagen dann dann
erschließt sich mir nicht eine weitere
Aufrüstung aber nicht gesagt dass diese
100 Milliarden berechtigt sind in der
Art und Weise wie sie dann umgesetzt
werden weil wir haben einen sehr gutes
Beispiel gerade aus den skandinavischen
Staaten Norwegen zum Beispiel die haben
ein kleines Militär und sind aber hoch
professionell mit der besten Ausrüstung
die man sich nur vorstellen kann und das
für die breite Masse da kriege ich
Gänsehaut wenn ich daran und denke weil
viele von unseren Jungs ähm arktischen
dort ausgebildet worden und du kommst da
halt hin und spielst hier eigentlich in
der zweiten Bundesliga im Militär und
wirst dann dort von naja von der von der
Basis von der Basis Soldaten ausgel weil
du eigentlich gar keine Ausrüstung hast
die für die Arktis das geht natürlich
überhaupt
Auslandseinsatz sie wissen wovon sie
reden sie waren in Afghanistan unter
anderem und sie haben dort diese
Erfahrungen auch gemacht sie haben genau
gesehen was dort passiert wie wird das
auf Sie wenn es jetzt ja gut dann haben
wir halt keine Regensachen dann halt
natürlich hier und es muss auch
vernünftige Winterklamotten die sind
doch klar also
verteidigungsfähig sollen wir die
Bundeswehr nicht machen also die Frage
ist was verteidigungsfähig ist aber
natürlich permanent im Ausland rumhüpfen
und unsere Freiheit den Afghanistan
verteidigen wollen muss grandios
gescheitert ist und dann steht da
stellt sich natürlich die Frage was
haben wir eigentlich für Geld für Pulver
doch was sinnvolle gewesen die wo sind
das Geld ja genau zu klären das zum
Beispiel die Soldaten die zum Beispiel
ein Wintertraining machen muss ja
vorsichtig dass die die Klamotten haben
dass sie doch auch vernünftig gehalten
werden also ich weiß wie das früher oft
im Gebirge auch bei -20 30 Grad ich weiß
wie das ist wenn es einen friert und da
braucht man vernünftige Klamotten das
ist dieses grundsätzlich diese 100
Milliarden mehr die beschlossen worden
sind ich halte es auch für notwendig und
sinnvoll wäre nicht wie sieht's jetzt
hier sagen Aufrüstung das klingt jetzt
so als würde man damit die Bundeswehr
für irgendwelche noch mehr militärische
vielleicht sogar offensiv Aktionen
ausrüsten es geht ja nicht um Aufrüstung
es geht um Ausrüstung und das finde ich
deswegen sollte man das auch sagen es
geht darum unsere Bundeswehr die
zunächst mal so Landesverteidigung nötig
ist und darüber hinaus auch Bündnis
Verpflichtungen hat besser als tüchtig
dass sie diesen beiden Aufgaben
nachkommen kann und dazu finde ich es
vor dem Hintergrund des Ukraine Krieges
sehr sehr vernünftig und sinnvoll dass
man gesagt hat jawohl wir wollen dieses
zwei Pfad Ziel beschreiten jetzt und ihr
wollt wir machen mit einem
Sondervermögen ein zusätzlichen
Vertrauen und natürlich die Jungs Beweis
für unsere Landesverteidigung das finde
ich sehr vernünftig das Afghanistan
gescheitert ist dass man in die Bildung
und die Eisenbahn investieren muss
natürlich aber nicht das eine wenn man
muss das eine tun und das andere zu
lassen
herrschaftszeiten wir gehen jetzt nur
200 wir hatten für Gas und und und und
und Strompreise kommen noch dazu und
jetzt gehen
wir im Haushalt also was da gemacht wird
ist wirklich dass wir ein Problem
sondern ich sage immer wir haben ja nun
entlüftungsventilator ist ja eine kleine
auch jetzt wieder Rüstung
Richtung
für die Soldaten
für die eigene Landesverteidigung nicht
zum rumsaußen in der Welt und zweiten
geben dass die Menschen die da drin
Dienst tun dass die auch vernünftig
behandelt vernünftig ausgerüstet werden
und dann brauchen wir eine
ein Militär die suchstrukturiert ist
dass sie vor allen Dingen die
Landesverteidigung gewährleisten kann
und die Mittel da bin ich ja dann
durchaus bei Ihnen die braucht man auch